For this challenge problem, imagine that we have three charges here
and they're arrange in this equilateral triangle shape
so the distance between any of the two charges is the same.
This also means that this angles here are all equal to 60 degrees.
All right--so it turns out that when you calculate the net force acting on each one of these charges,
you get the following results that for this particle the net force is straight down
and for this particle the net force points at this angle 23.41 degrees with this horizontal line here.
Using this information alone, can you tell me what the charges for this particle and this particle
in terms of the charge on this particle q.
To clarify, if you think this particle here has a charge five times greater than this one,
but has the opposite sign, you'd say that this particle has a charge of -5q.
All right. Good luck solving this problem and please feel free to discuss it in the forum.